this video is brought to you by
established titles
[Music]
what's up everyone michael here to ask
how much have you accomplished today
whether you ran a marathon read moby
dick or continue the ambitious project
of organically fusing your butt to the
couch you might be thinking not nearly
enough lately it seems like everyone
feels pressure to be more productive and
this craze to get things done can leave
us all feeling like failures and on its
face this is kind of ironic while we did
see a rare slump in non-farm
productivity earlier this year that
trend is expected to reverse and even
though productivity growth has been
smaller in recent years american workers
are still working more efficiently than
they were even just a couple of decades
ago this makes us wonder why are we all
so obsessed with productivity and what's
more is this obsession actually
productive let's find out in this
wisecrack edition on productivity are we
optimizing ourselves to death you don't
have to search for hashtag productivity
on instagram to notice our modern
fixation on overachieving for years
books like getting things done the art
of stress-free productivity and the
4-hour work week have sold by the
millions the current productivity
bestseller is atomic habits which
promises that small but meaningful
habits can create staggering changes in
your life a sales pitch that like so
many of its quadruple your productivity
forefathers feels too good to be true
and if you're too drained to muster the
willpower to plow through a whole book
about the willpower effect rest easy
there are multiple apps eager to break
it down chapter by chapter in 10 minutes
or less legit you go getting done 10
minutes at a time the industry of big
productivity has yielded scores of
influencers who espouse their secrets to
log in shorter work weeks emptying
inboxes and tripling output every book
seems to have a patented gimmick whether
it's a productivity pyramid a 20-minute
routine to optimize your whole day or a
list of habits you can copy from
successful people the methods behind
these gurus madness vary some suggest
outsourcing secretarial tasks to
underpaid workers in the developing
world back in the day that was just
called colonialism some instruct you to
start each day with the hardest project
on your plate which it compares to
an amphibian and one guy from the 1960s
urges you to write your own gravestone
inscription as a thought experiment to
supposedly gain perspective on how
you're living your life my gravestone
would say he died as he lived wondering
if the youtube comments were right if
productivity is measured by how much you
accomplish and how quickly it's no
wonder that our obsession with
productivity has an equally sadistic
twin our obsession with time in 1982
physician larry dosie dubbed the
american fixation on the second hand of
the clock time sickness and a recent
stanford study found this fixation is
legitimately bad for our health
apparently obsessing over the time you
spend on a task can increase your stress
levels a whopping 25
but skyrocketing cortisol levels aren't
about to stop the booming productivity
or optimization movement employers are
increasingly turning to digital
self-tracking technologies to monitor
workers activities whether in the form
of digital wellness tools to encourage
employees to walk more or computer
surveillance programs though once
seemingly exclusive to the hellscape of
amazon warehouses an increasing number
of workplaces are automating technology
to track their workers productivity
affecting everyone from lawyers to
accountants and wouldn't you know they
are totally thrilled with this no
they're not we're just kidding they're
miserable one financial executive
describes how every minute of her work
day is monitored and she literally is
only paid for the minutes that her
computer deems productive and yet most
americans are working more hours than
their parents did and as we've
established at higher rates of
productivity not to mention lower wages
so it's worth asking why isn't what
we're doing just
enough according to sociologist carolyn
chen our obsession with always achieving
more is symptomatic of a larger
phenomenon first seen on a wide scale in
silicon valley specifically chen argues
work is becoming increasingly central to
our lives and identities and has even
started to fill the role of religion she
writes work has become a spiritual
practice that inspires religious fervor
people are not selling their souls at
work rather work is where they find
their souls and if work is akin to our
secular religion our productivity is a
measure of our faithfulness companies
know this in recent years they've taken
steps to provide what chen calls
pastoral and spiritual care at work from
weekly meditation sessions to
self-fulfillment workshops to team
building exercises companies are
offering many of the trappings once
associated with spiritual life all in
the name of boosting our productivity so
was the secular religiousification of
the american workplace inevitable
arguably not as social researcher david
frain writes if work is indeed a central
source of sociality rights status and
belonging this situation is a social and
historical construction and not a fixed
feature of some natural order so where
does our fixation on our work and our
productivity really come from well
buckle up because we're about to dive in
but first i want to tell you about this
video's sponsor established titles and i
also want to make an important
announcement on all future videos i will
be introducing myself as laird michael
that's all thanks to established titles
which is a project that lets you buy as
little as one square foot of dedicated
land in scotland and that's enough to
earn you the title of laird but
established titles is about more than
just hooking you up with a new way to
introduce yourself at parties it's also
a fun and effective way to support
scotland's biodiversity and aforestation
efforts around the world so here's how
it works first you purchase your
dedicated land on a private estate in
edelston scotland you'll receive an
official certificate with a crest along
with a unique plot number at the same
time established titles will team up
with global charities one tree planted
and trees for the future to plant a tree
in conjunction with your order
established titles is also a great gift
because who expects to hear happy
birthday oh yeah you're a laird now now
alternatively you can opt for a couple's
pack which ensures adjoining plots of
land for you and your beloved and
established titles told me that the
first 200 people that purchase a title
pack using my link will effectively be
next to my plot within a few minutes
walking distance depending on how many
of you want to become a lord or lady we
could build our own little wisecrack
kingdom now established titles is
currently running a labor day sale and
you can use code wisecrack at checkout
to get an additional 10 percent off your
order so go to
establishedtitles.comwisecrack
and get 10
off your
plot of scottish land now
back to the show society has a valued
productivity since ancient times
philosophers like aristotle and plato
spoke admirably about knowledge driven
achievements and skilled craftsmanship
but at the same time they cautioned that
zest for work should be balanced with a
full-throated embrace of leisure time
and notably their mode of work sitting
around thinking for hours on end would
probably be viewed today as unproductive
or navel-gazy but we don't think so
philosophy is hard work and someone's
got to do it but as is the case with
just about everything christianity
changed the way we viewed work when it
reframed labor as a punishment cast upon
the apple curious by a wrathful god as
philosopher camillo bernary writes
ancient and medieval catholicism
glorified work mostly as an expiation of
sin i.e a reparation for our spiritual
bad behavior and once christians got
gung-ho about work criminalizing anybody
with a lazy bone in their body
inevitably followed in the late middle
ages idle behavior was treated as a
crime often punished with a public
flogging followed by forced labor and
this continued for centuries author
suzanna wadiga points out that well into
the 1800s almost identical laws were
used in europe and the united states in
times of crisis to regulate the
distribution of cheap workforces control
population mobility and stabilize state
power in america they were called [ __ ]
acts and violators were forcibly
engraved with intricate horizontal
tattoos on their lower backs but while
christianity always valued work things
went into overdrive in the 16th and 17th
centuries two big things spurred this
productivity happy revolution the first
was the protestant reformation which
transformed the perception of work by
treating labor not as a punishment but
as a virtuous pursuit in and of itself
to be undertaken with zeal specifically
calvinists believed that success in this
lifetime was a sign of predestined
salvation so it made sense to hustle
your butt off in order to prove to
yourself and all your buddies that you
were heaven-bound the second big change
was the advancement of the humble clock
see according to philosopher george
woodcock for most of western history
time was conceived of as a sort of
flowing amorphous ethereal thing and
calculated pretty vaguely but the
invention of and then advancements to
the clock from minute hands around the
late 1600s to accurate second hands a
century or so later altered our
conception of time and consequently it
altered how much humans felt they should
accomplish during that time as woodcock
writes the clock turns time from a
process of nature into a commodity that
can be measured and bought and sold the
clock happy post-reformation world got
another boost from the enlightenment
which among other things valorized
mankind's ability to perform productive
labor at the time labor was frequently
perceived positively as a commodity and
as a source of social respectability
according to scholar deborah simonton at
the same time the west was undergoing
intense economic growth and expansion as
markets blossomed work became more
regimented thus timekeeping became
linked to industriousness founding
father and patron saint of to-do list
benjamin franklin observed time is money
one thing on his to-do list was
definitely get syphilis because he had
syphilis simonson explains enlightenment
ideas and burgeoning entrepreneurship
colluded to improve efficiency and
output but the joy of an industrious
day's work might not have been enough on
its own to catapult american culture
into a flurry of productivity
sociologist max weber argues that the
rapid rise of capitalism can be
attributed significantly to the
lingering power of the protestant work
ethic remember the protestant work ethic
conveniently equated economic success
with moral virtue and no wealthy
capitalists were gonna be mad at that
the protestant mindset of discipline and
regulation also facilitated the
expansion of punitive policies against
vagrants including mass arrests and
forced labor which basically just meant
making life hell for vagrants wanderers
and anyone who couldn't seem to hold
down a job that's important because a
big part of valorizing work has always
been about the elites wanting to keep
the pores busy so they wouldn't indulge
in naughty diversions like drinking or
sex as history's favorite short king
napoleon wrote the more my people work
the less vices they will have society is
growing fixation on productivity and
demonization of laziness provided a
secular substitute for the religious
discipline that was falling out of
fashion the valorization of work in
america got another big boost during the
second industrial revolution a
combination of lingering reformation
views victorian morality around work
ethic and delayed gratification as well
as that all american ethos of
bootstrapping your way to success all
congealed into a culture of intense
industriousness it was now every man's
duty to work hard and produce useful
things and with production speeding up
thanks to the newfangled mechanics of
everything from the steamboat to the
sewing machine workers were quickly
transported from hand making goods at
home to working in factories we talked
about this in our video on working from
home but this moment in history is
important to today's video too basically
early factory workers were not exactly
what you'd call
well-behaved they went from making their
own hours at their own homes to being
subjected to grueling endless work days
in unpleasant factories unsurprisingly
absenteeism was a huge problem people
were very often drunk on the job which
despite what they might have thought
didn't actually make them funnier as
historian daniel t rodgers writes by
reporting irregularly for work moving
restlessly from job to job or engaging
in slowdowns and work restrictions
industrial laborers stubbornly resisted
the new work discipline the factory
masters tried to impose upon enter
mechanical engineer frederick w taylor
who became obsessed with expediting
production processes in the late 19th
century factory which basically meant
wrangling workers he realized that
because of their past as skilled
craftsman workers possessed knowledge
and dexterity that actually made them
more valuable than the foreman managing
them this in taylor's view was dangerous
it gave workers way too much power over
the means of production so he came up
with a way to increase efficiency and
consolidate control much higher up the
food chain all via a new field of study
called scientific management which was
later dubbed taylorism as john zurzon
writes scientific management began to
take shape in the 1880s as the way to
break the workers threatening resistance
the heart of this approach is the
systematic reduction of work into
discrete routinized tasks totally
separated from any policy decisions
about the job now adam smith had
conceived of the assembly line over a
century earlier in his book wealth of
nations and such systems had already
existed in american meat packing
factories but taylor put this process on
steroids breaking production into
minuscule individual tasks and assigning
workers the same task to do over and
over again at the fastest possible speed
which is not at all a recipe for slowly
losing your [ __ ] mind as taylor's
methods were widely adopted workers went
from producing say
a shoe or a carriage at their own pace
so performing what rogers calls
specialized repetitious machine paced
and often deadingly simple actions
what's more workers were now de-skilled
and disempowered they didn't know how
the wider factory worked they only knew
how to perform their specific tasks
effectively the first major methods of
increasing productivity were largely
about management and posing control on
workers taylor's influence was vast and
he wasn't alone other efficiency experts
most notably frank and lillian gilbreth
the real family behind cheaper by the
dozen sought to expedite productivity
specifically by analyzing the [ __ ] out
of workers physical movements they broke
down every work task into individual
motions which they call the units of
thurb legs i.e gilbreth spelled
backwards they filmed workers performing
acts of labor and studied each frame
attempting to cut out unnecessary
motions in search of what they called
the one best way of performing each task
notably lillian gilbert's work after her
husband frank's death was focused on
promoting domestic science i.e bringing
the art of efficiency into the household
as factories grew more efficient the
thinking went why shouldn't housewives
also benefit from these methods gilbreth
and other home efficiency experts taught
women everything from the best posture
for washing dishes to the fastest way to
can baby food and encourage them to find
ways to maximize their efficiency by
reducing the motions required to perform
each task another thing that gilbert's
realized was that worker psychology that
is their temperament and contentment was
also essential to productivity in what
was basically the first rumbling of
human resources they encouraged
employers to make workers surroundings
more pleasant provide magazines for them
to read and even set up suggestion boxes
where workers can make other requests
the silicon valley startups that feel
more like cool coffee shops than offices
have their roots in this understanding
that happy workers tend to work harder
and faster helped along by taylorism and
the production needs of two world wars
productivity rates in america began
soaring in the 1920s and continued that
trend up into the 70s and despite the
glaring issues with treating people like
machines there seemed to be obvious
benefits to increasing productivity as
frain explains in the early 20th century
business leaders assumed that the
natural results of improved production
techniques would be an increase in free
time economist john maynard keynes
predicted that his grandchildren would
work 15 hour weeks keynes's prediction
seems naive in hindsight but when he was
writing in 1930 it made sense after all
production had been rising and
unprecedented 5.3 a year over the
previous decade how many buttons and
radios and toothbrushes could one
country need and there was precedent for
shortening the work week a scholar
benjamin honeycutt explains in the 1920s
work weeks had been steadily decreasing
from 70 hours or more in the early 1800s
to a more manageable 50 hours by the
1920s and there was reason to think that
newly increased productivity would lead
to even more leisure time but faced with
this opportunity to make their workers
lives happier more relaxing and more
fulfilling businesses said
actually yeah we're good we don't we
don't need to do that we're just gonna
make them keep working why as social
researcher david frain explains the idea
of less work and more leisure was
completely counter-intuitive to the
dogma of economic growth basically now
that they can produce goods faster and
more cheaply instead of letting workers
take a siesta they decided to just
produce a ton more goods and maximize
profits then there was the whole
morality side of things rich people
don't love it when poor people have too
much free time sigmund freud even
worried that if labor hours were reduced
emancipated working-class americans
would fall into an orgy astic rule of
nature and indulge in their darkest
predilections like incest cannibalism
and murder companies wanted to keep
growing and elites wanted workers to
keep logging long hours in the factories
as a result america was producing
massive quantities of consumer goods so
what do you do with a big surplus of
products you start hawking that via what
historian edward s kaldrick dubbed the
new economic gospel of consumption of
the 1920s or as scholar kathy weeks
writes consumption emerged as an
essential economic practice producers
were expected to do double duty as
aesthetically indulgent consumers but
how are people supposed to be good
consumers if they weren't making very
much money henry ford solved that puzzle
when he started paying his workers five
dollars a day twice the market rate
while not his primary motivation this
did have the effect of making his cars
more affordable to his workers thus
expanding his market it was a huge
success ford doubled his profits in just
two years and this quickly convinced
other employers to follow suit and raise
wages according to labor economist
harley shaiken
what that gave us was an industrial
middle class and an economy that was
driven by consumer demand basically for
the first time people could buy fun
things of course it's no coincidence
that just as american businesses had way
more products to sell we saw the
simultaneous emergence of modern
advertising spurred on by the
psychological approach of freud's nephew
edward bernays advertisements evolved
from their traditional practice of
appealing to people with reason i.e
bragging about the high quality of their
toothpaste and instead started relying
on emotional and symbolic appeals i.e
promising that this toothpaste will get
you laid this approach was necessary
because sellers with massive surpluses
were no longer simply catering to
consumers basic needs now they were
creating entirely new desires as bernays
wrote today supply must actively seek to
create its corresponding demand and
cannot afford to wait until the public
asks for its product it must maintain
constant touch through advertising and
propaganda to assure itself the
continuous demand such began a virtuous
cycle of people becoming more productive
while earning higher wages and thus
businesses had more products to sell
which they then peddled to their workers
because they could now afford to buy for
fun so everybody wins and it all worked
out this is the end of the video of
course it's not it gets bad again now
ever since productivity became a driving
concern around the turn of the 20th
century it had mostly been a top-down
process of managers spurring
productivity in their workers through
surveillance discipline and
encouragement that was about to shift
dramatically in the 50s and 60s with the
rise of knowledge work i.e work that
forces you to think for a living because
knowledge work was more complex varied
and nuanced than say a factory assembly
line of workers mass-producing widgets
productivity started becoming more
difficult to monitor and to quantify
this was about to change the entire way
we conceive of getting stuff done at the
time management consultant peter drucker
argued that personal autonomy would
become the defining feature of the new
knowledge-based corporate world as
individual workers became responsible
for tracking their own productivity he
wrote the knowledge worker cannot be
supervised closely or in detail he must
direct himself as the impetus fell on
individuals to self-manage their
productivity many sought advice on how
the heck they were supposed to do that
fittingly this is when productivity
self-help books first became a fixture
of the book industry the trend kicked
off with james mackays the management of
time in 1959 which featured quotes like
tomorrow you promise yourself will be
different yet tomorrow is too often a
repetition of today beginning in the 60s
the productivity guru emerged as a
trustworthy figure offering firm but
reassuring advice weeks explains that
gurus typically suggest some kind of
reformed daily routine to insert ritual
awareness into one's day much like a
religious refrain importantly the
personal productivity industry often
flourishes during economic downturns in
the recession of the mid-1970s books
like how to get control of your life and
time urged anxious workers to make the
most of their coffee break by learning a
new word from their dictionary by the
early 90s yet another recession had
books like self-discipline in 10 days
promising to help you go from thinking
to doing this literature was serving an
important purpose it offered hope for
workers pursuing success in an
increasingly competitive job market
right as layoffs and corporate
downsizing were becoming the new normal
and weeks argues that over the course of
the greed is good 80s and the dial-up
sound dominated 90s productivity took on
the thrust of puritan principles that
can be embraced either adjacent to or in
spite of religious belief because it
holds the same qualities of disciplined
practice as productivity solidified
itself as the individual impetus of each
worker busyness started to be seen as an
ideal and in recent years it's even
become an aspirational status symbol
according to researcher sylvia belaza in
pursuit of such status we've all become
accustomed to managing our own
productivity some of this is
circumstantial the job market is more
competitive than ever wages haven't kept
up with inflation workplace expectations
are at an all-time high and we're taught
to feel lucky to even have a job all
these circumstances combine to create a
profound anxiety amongst workers and
guess what
that's great for business philosopher
young chilhan explains that anxiety
increases productivity while political
theorist neil valaillae adds an anxious
subject works harder partly out of fear
of losing their job in short we're
obsessed with productivity in large part
because
well
we have to be we live in a time of
intense precarity and competition and
the stability of many career paths is
haunted by ghost of future automation
industrial revolution era efficiency
experts were mostly concerned with
disciplining workers bodies to make them
behave more like machines but for
today's knowledge workers han notes
productivity is not to be enhanced by
overcoming physical resistance so much
as by optimizing psychic or mental
processes and now we're the ones
optimizing ourselves this is arguably an
essential feature of neo-liberalism i.e
a liberal capitalist ideology that
emphasizes free markets and individual
responsibility as sociologist deborah
lupton notes neoliberalism tends to
favor soft over hard power writing that
instead of relying on coercive measures
in managing and regulating their
citizens neo-liberal political systems
invest faith in the voluntary take-up of
imperatives by the citizens themselves
citizens believe that certain acts are
in their own best interest or are
integral to ideal selfhood she cites
productivity as a prominent imperative
taken up by people in pursuit of
self-betterment han contends that such a
fixation is actually a form of
self-oppression he writes as an
entrepreneur of himself the neoliberal
achievement subject engages in auto
exploitation willingly and even
passionate as such he notes perpetual
self-optimization represents nothing so
much as a highly efficient mode of
domination and exploitation and in this
case he says the psyche itself is being
exploited so while taylor had to
implement his time-saving techniques in
a top-down way to wrangle disgruntled
drunk and decidedly ungrateful workers
we now willingly impose pomodoro timers
5 am wake-up calls and expensive
nootropic regimens on ourselves as such
the worker becomes what han calls a
self-illuminating self-surveilling
subject he argues that we're
functionally in a panopticon of our own
making one where there is no difference
between guard and inmate put differently
the guard or vigilant manager is living
inside our head rent free as we've seen
the religious zeal behind personal
productivity can be traced all the way
back to capitalism spiritual roots and
calvinism but as weeks points out
today's cult of productivity differs
from other religions because it is
entirely inwardly oriented it's a total
devotion to one's self and one's
achievement and it's a pretty empty
ethos in our obsession with maximizing
our output the actual value of that
output becomes almost irrelevant there's
no driving purpose behind the concept of
pure productivity other than a very
simple market logic that any production
is good production as anthropologist
david graber writes we have become a
civilization based on work as an end and
meaning in itself graber argues that
many of today's workers are toiling away
at both jobs defined by meaningless work
in such an environment it's no wonder
that as greg notes productivity becomes
a framework for knowing what to do in
the absence of a guiding principle for
doing it our quest for productivity
arguably affords us a sense of control
in a fast-paced workplace as greg
explains time management celebrates
command and control the idea of time
sovereignty holds faith in the idea that
time is territory that can be conquered
we can't do anything about next month's
layoffs but damn it we can milk every
last second out of our work day
conquering time comforts us in an era of
profound insecurity we feel an affirming
twang of self-determination every time
we skip lunch with our work pals to eat
at our desk in this way greg sees time
management as inherently isolating a
form of training through which workers
become capable of the ever more daring
acts of solitude and ruthlessness
necessary to produce career competence
and all of this focus on our own
productivity has the effect of
distracting us from the very reasons
we're pushed to be so productive in the
first place as han writes even class
struggle has transformed into an inner
struggle against oneself when we're
pushing ourselves to be more productive
we're not questioning or agitating
against the systems that have allowed
america's sweeping productivity gains to
mostly flow to the top instead we're
trying to control our circumstances by
controlling our brains kind of feels
like trying to stop the titanic from
sinking by making sure that your
personal life vest is on real tight in
this way the culture of productivity is
inherently alienating as greg notes
productivity's inward focus further
entrenches the erasure of collective
thinking that the first efficiency
engineers sought to accomplish just as
taylor took the factory's collective
production processes and divided it into
individual tasks our contemporary
productivity obsession makes corporate
success a matter of individual
responsibility and then it pits those
individuals against one another as
philosopher pierre bordeaux observes
under neoliberalism competition that
once existed between say two competing
corporations has increasingly shifted to
competition amongst individuals within
the same firms today your real rival is
just one cubicle over at the same time
the atomized nature of modern work
culture perpetuates another neoliberal
truism that any individual's failures
come from their own moral or
intellectual shortcomings han argues
that people who fail in the neoliberal
achievement society see themselves as
responsible for their luck and feel
shame instead of questioning society or
the system maybe your adhd makes keeping
up with hundreds of emails a day an
insurmountable challenge maybe your
dyslexia makes copy editing legal
documents a slow and laborious task or
maybe you're just bored of spreadsheets
and bureaucracy and stupid corporate
jargon damn you sound pretty lazy so
don't come knocking on my door asking
for handouts in some anyone who doesn't
commit to fully optimizing themselves is
seen as inadequate even delinquent as
graeber notes we've come to believe that
men and women who do not work harder
than they wish at jobs they do not
particularly enjoy are bad people
unworthy of love care or assistance from
their communities it is as if we have
collectively acquiesced to our own
enslavement so how's an overly
productive society supposed to cope
recently an influx of new books like
jenny odell's how to do nothing have
squarely taken on productivity culture
odell argues that cultivating decidedly
unproductive practices in her case
spending time at parks watching birds is
a crucial step in taking back our own
attention and building forms of
resistance to capitalism's limitless
drive for production this argument
suggests that as weeks puts it there is
a value of non-work time as a resource
for social cultural and political
projects of trans valuation that is to
say we have to take time off from work
in order to have the time to question
whether work should be our highest
priority in the first place
scholar brian o'connor furthers this
point arguing that there's a profound
freedom in preserving idle time
explicitly not defined by achievement he
argues that idleness is an implicit
resistance to specific recommendations
about how one ought to live the need for
progress prestige or success through
work and it is also the pleasure that we
experience when we are free to live
without those expectations maybe we
could learn a thing or two from all
those day drunk factory workers after
all but if being idle for even a minute
sounds awful greg proposes a different
way to radicalize productivity culture
she writes that we need to move our
aspirations for productivity from the
corporate to the collective interest
productive atmospheres are truly
revolutionary when they initiate a form
of collective solidarity that is not
dependent on labor and that sounds
suspiciously similar to something amazon
and starbucks workers are currently
fighting for now arguably
personal productivity is an
internalization of the obsessive growth
mindset that has long dominated american
economic life we should produce not
because it's valuable but because we can
but just as dissenters have reacted to
productivity culture on an individual
level we see a similar tide rising on a
societal level with the emergence of the
deep growth movement drawing on
eco-liberalism which seeks to balance
individualism and industry with
ecological concerns growth advocates
argue that pursuing unchecked economic
growth is antithetical to protecting the
planet from environmental catastrophe
they advocate for vastly ramping down
production and consumption and
prioritizing social and ecological
well-being instead as economic
anthropologist jason hickle writes we
need to slow it all down slow down the
mad pace of extraction production and
waste and slow down the mad pace of our
lives in this way the de-growth movement
compels us to also question our personal
fixation on productivity which is really
just the atomized version of society's
ceaseless growth mindset and this seems
like a healthy thing to do because if
productivity culture isn't making us
happier and if endlessly growing
production is slowly destroying the
planet perhaps it's time to think a
little less about getting things done
and a little more about getting things
right but what do you all think is
productivity culture toxic or just a
harmless quest for self-improvement and
are we all still just protestant work
ethic in ourselves to death let us know
in the comments be sure to like the
video to tell us that we worked hard
enough on it shout out to our patrons
for all their support do check out our
patreon page if you have it in a while
and as always thanks for watching later
[Music]
you